from a young age we're taught it's a
terrible thing so when we feel it as we
all do we're inclined not to examine it
we just feel ashamed and guilty but
that's a pity because envy like fear is
an important emotion that exists in all
of us for some good reasons it's there
to help us know what we want it's a call
to action that should be heeded contain
and garbled but important messages about
what we should be doing with the rest of
our lives if we can get past the
humiliation of envious feelings we can
start to see them as a set of clues
about what we might do next we should
study and maybe even record on paper the
situations and people that make us
envious we might learn to keep an envied
diary
it will contain fragments of a future
self trying to break through we often
forget that the things we admire don't
just belong to one specific very
attractive life they can be pursued in
lesser Rico but still very real doses in
countless other places opening up the
possibility of creating many smaller
more manageable and more realistic
versions of the lives we are drawn to
let's no longer just think we're bad
people just for envy let's do something
far more productive become diligent and
careful students of our most persistent
envious feelings they're trying to tell
us something
and we should listen
you